[Applause]
that's right
and today's doggie bag it's a beauty
company called sunday riley i'm a big
fan now
this is auto correct it's for dark
circles under your eyes
puffiness and wrinkles it is
instantaneous
game changer it has caffeine in it and
this beautiful reflective like
plant extract and the second you put it
on your eyes look different give me a
pump
i suffer from dark circles and one pump
if you can see on my hand
it literally covers both eyes now it's
65 a bottle which is usually
like more pricier than i recommend but
when you break it down that's like 65
cents a day for a
truly game-changing like product so i
can't recommend this more it
is worth it today's pick is the
georgia louise cryo freeze tool
okay so rossi i split these up they come
in a pack of two
um so but i gave one to rossi that's
what friends do
thank you very much that's right and
vogue recently did a piece all about the
benefits of
facial massage and i have to say that
i've played with a lot of facial
massagers and some are effective and
some are not
this is going to change your life what
does it do you put it in
the freezer and then if you're like me
and you're a naughty little porker and
eat chinese food all night but you need
to go to work the next day and you wake
up
swollen you rub these and you do the two
yep there i am
it changes it brings circulation it
deposits
it completely changes the shape of your
face so cold
and it brings a ton of rosiness
and color back in when i started these
the other day
i did it for a good 10 15 minutes i
committed
oh my gosh i was pale and plump
and not in a good way yes and by the
time i was done
i was gaunt and rosy and felt like a
million bucks that completely
changed my face i think it's giving me
brain freeze but i like it
and today it's crazy liberty's hair da
for dog
that's right this is a non-toxic dog
safe die
perfect for your spunky little pooch and
check this out
oh my gosh i want that cat right now
guess what oh my gosh olive did this
on lucy our dog do we have that picture
yeah there you go
wow that's right i loved olive's
placement because i had no idea where
this was going on a big white canvas
like lucy
that's great isn't that cute and it's
really great it lasted
like a couple shampoos and then went
away today it is
magic in a tube this is perfect for
really dry lips
ross this is dr dan's cordy balm
okay well i i want to know because i am
fiercely loyal to my
lip balm a different brand i know you
even have it in your pocket oh it's
literally 24 7. okay well get ready
because my dermatologist
recommended this to me and it worked
when nothing else did in fact in our
household if somebody like gets really
injured we're like grab the cordy bomb
okay it's it's just a lifesaver it works
like nothing else i've ever used
there's been over a million tubes sold
because it is a miracle creation
and it's a medicated bomb with one key
ingredient hydrocortisone
so it moisturizes and heals another
thing it did
is i'm actually allergic to a dye in
lipsticks that used to be commonly found
they're sort of phasing it out
but this healed it what yes really it's
medicine it's much more than a lip balm
[Music]
you